[Music]  chippie hash was on the VMAs she threw a  little shade at five age she basically  was congratulating Camilla on all of her  success and just said hey fifth harmony  like from home  oh well you know Nikki came to Norma's  offense in particular but I want to ask  you I mean what kind of success you see  the girls having is if you're gonna be  similar to 1d where everyone kind of had  a piece of the pie you know I was gonna  is there enough room for all of them I  hope so I mean look vessels happen with  the One Direction guys I mean Camilla  was the first to say she wanted to go  solo not be we batter on that and last  night was a huge night for her but all  those girls I mean they're all talented  and so I'm happy for all of them that's  look that's the reason why we do these  shows right yeah you know I think  lightning strikes five times for you so  [Music]  [Applause]